les patrons veulent faciliter
l'intégration des réfugiés en entreprise
dans une tribune parue dans le jdd elle
dit chef d'entreprise de grands groupes
français et internationaux à l'instar de
l'oréal ou de bnp paribas ont annoncé
s'être réunis sous l'égide d'un
collectif en faveur des réfugiés baptisé
nos réfugiés sont des talents il
s'engage à accompagner à intégrer
davantage les réfugiés dans nos sociétés
on va en parler tout de suite avec
pierre-henri il est président de france
fraternité pierre-henri bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france on le
disait donc les patrons de dix grands
groupes un dont bnp paribas adecco ou
encore michelin ont lancé un appel en
faveur de l'intégration d'entreprises
des personnes réfugiées alors comment
est ce que vous avez perçu cet appel
mois de bord l'appel n'est pas nouveau
c'est fait maintenant plus de six ans
que les chefs de grands groupes de
grandes entreprises travaillent sur
l'intégration des réfugiés alors je
rappelle pour les téléspectateurs
mais pour les auditeurs de rtl que les
réfugiés sont des personnes qui ont
obtenu la protection de la france un
droit de séjour de près de dix ans est
un droit de travail immédiat et que ces
personnes avaient des compétences dans
leur pays d'origine et que ses
compétences peuvent tout à fait être
mises en oeuvre et à disposition des
entreprises donc c'est très symbolique
cet engagement et c'est une invitation
faite à l'ensemble des packs trop de ce
pays est bien de faire en sorte lorsque
c'est possible lorsque les compétences
sont reconnues
l'un d'empocher tout simplement des
réfugiés alors certains notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux on a pu lire
dénonce une pseudo bienveillance
hypocrite en y voyant une main d'oeuvre
moins chère en fait pour les entreprises
est ce que c'est le cas mais écoutez ça
c'est totalement ridicule pour une
raison des sommes c'est que de toute
façon leurs beaux chalets se mise au
compte général qui ont en france
personne par exemple ne peut travailler
à plein temps c'est-à-dire 151 heures
par mois sans être payés au smig donc
dire qu'il y à une pression sur les
salaires par l'intermédiaire de l'
embauche de réfugiés est totalement
absurde il ya une une réglementation qui
doit être assurée et puis la vérité
c'est aussi les suivantes
il y a aussi un certain nombre d'emplois
qui ne sont pas occupés aujourd'hui dans
des secteurs sous tension par les
nationaux et que et ces secteurs ont un
besoin urgent de main d'oeuvre que
peuvent leur fournir des gens qui je le
rappelle sont en situation régulière
parce que reconnu par l'office français
de protection des réfugiés et des
apatrides et la cour nationale du droit
d'asile
en gros chaque année il ya un peu plus
de cent mille demandeurs d'asile qui
viennent demander protection à la france
et sur ce dont vous vous en avait
environ 35 à 40 milles qui obtiennent la
protection est un droit de séjour et de
travail de dix ans et donc il faut bien
que ces gens vivent de manière autonome
est un travail et l'engagement des pétro
c'est tout simplement de dire ben il ya
des compétences
regardez aussi de ce côté là est-ce que
ça va venir
elle est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya
aussi une vraie politique de recrutement
qui est mise en place pour aller
chercher justement ces personnes
réfugiées ou alors on échoue
sur un effet d'annonce de la
communication vie finalement de la part
de ces jeunes vous entend alors là c'est
un petit peu plus compliqué parce que
dans les faits sur le terrain ils
embaucheront sont que complexe et il ya
un véritable travail qui est encore à
effectuer mais vous savez l'exemple est
aussi de la hiérarchie et donc à partir
du moment où dans un grand journal n'est
pas trop s'engage pour embaucher des
réfugiés peut-être que dans les échelons
intermédiaires
ça va faciliter les choses
mais il n'y a pas une filière spécifique
des mises en oeuvre pour embaucher des
réfugiés simplement il faut étudier les
cb et puis en fait là
la question centrale c'est celle de la
maîtrise de la langue vous savez vous
êtes embauché dans une entreprise 3 ait
six vous parler la langue française donc
bien aussi un travail de la part des
réfugiés qui est absolument
indispensable
c'est tout simplement de maîtriser à
minima la langue pour pouvoir être
embauché dans une entreprise dans une
grande entreprise française
merci beaucoup pierre aurait d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci jrt franc
je le rappelle vous êtes prévient deux
ans fraternité